♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how Bigtable
can help you analyze large workloads.
Cloud Bigtable is a fully managed,
scalable NoSQL database
for large analytical
and operational workloads.
It is designed
as a sparsely populated table
that can scale to billions of rows
and thousands of columns,
enabling you to store terabytes
or even petabytes of data.
Bigtable is a key-value store
that supports high read
and write throughput
at low latency,
supporting millions
of requests per second.
Need to increase queries per second?
Just add more Bigtable nodes.
It is an ideal data source
for MapReduce-style operations
and integrates easily
with existing big data tools,
like Hadoop, Dataflow, and Dataproc.
To help you get started quickly,
it also supports
open-source HBase API standard.
Ready to set up Bigtable?
Get started by designing the schema,
planning out queries,
and designing a row key.
Once finalized, create a Bigtable instance
using this gcloud command,
Cloud Console, or the API.
In Bigtable, you write data once,
and it automatically replicates
where needed with eventual consistency,
giving you control for high availability
and isolation of read and write workloads.
Bigtable powers Google products
used by billions,
such as Search and Maps.
You can use it to store
and query your data, too,
including time series,
marketing, and financial data.
So, next time you're looking
to analyze large workloads,
take a minute to look at Bigtable.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/bigtable.
♪ [music] ♪